Hi, everyone.
So what I wanna show off today
is using
Zalando's
metrics adapter
in order to scale your Kubernetes deployment objects
using the horizontal pod autoscaler with custom metrics.
Those custom metrics are going to come from
InfluxDB running inside of your cluster,
and we do that by annotating the HPA
with a flux query.
Alright. So let's take a look at what's
going on.
Firstly,
we have to deploy the metrics adapter. This
code is in a repository. I'm not going
to go through it right now, but feel
free to take a look and I'll make
sure the links at the end.
We're deploying engine x because it's relatively easy
to force a scaling event using any HTTP
load stress tool.
We're using any containers just to make sure
that the bucket exists
and we have a sidecar container running telegraph.
That sidecar container is scraping the NGINX status
endpoint
to get a few basic stats from the
container itself.
We also have an HPA configured.
Now like I said at the start,
we're gonna annotate it with a flux query.
This flux query is going to run every
five seconds. It's going to pull out the
NGINX metrics,
and we're gonna kind of introspect this waiting
field. What we want to know is are
there any HTTP requests that are waiting
for something to handle it? When that number
gets too high, we have our goal being
it to be one or less, then we
want to scale up the number of pods
to be able to satisfy and handle that
traffic.
Okay.
So what we have running here on the
top
is just a watcher
monitoring all the pods and we can see
our NGINX HPA is running here. And we
have the two containers, which just means NGINX
with telegraph running side by side.
If I jump over to this other tab,
what we want to do is just take
a look
and see that we have influx DB running.
And I'm going to port forward to this
and show you the metrics.
It's InfluxDV799999999.
I jump up to my browser,
we can browse to influx
and we can log in.
There we go.
And if we take a look at the
metric explorer, we have our NGINX HPA bucket,
which was created by the end of container.
We have our NGINX measurement
and have a whole bunch of different fields
that we can use to determine how to
scale this pod.
And if we just take a look at
the waiting
field,
We'll see that, you know, it's zero zero
zero zero and except for my test over
here where I managed to cause the scaling
a bit earlier. It's been zero ever since.
So
the other thing that we want to do
is
now provide enough traffic
that we can see the scale
in real time.
Now in order to do that, I do
need to port forward one more time.
So we're going to jump up here and
we want to port forward to the engine
x pod so that my load balancing tool
which is running locally on my machine can
still hit it.
So we're gonna port forward.
I wonder if that's changed. Let's just double
check. It has not. So we're going to
expose engine X on port 9,000
locally on this machine.
Which means if I go into the same
directory, the command should be in my history.
But we can run BATIN and we're just
gonna tell it to go to local host
on 9,000 as support forward import.
We're going to run 512
concurrent go routines
and we wanna try and hit this with
200,000
requests.
If we hit return
and if we jump up here and we
just stick this on a cycle of refreshing,
we can see now that the waiting
is beginning to increase quite drastically.
And now right on queue, our watcher has
picked up that we have to spin up
more pods to handle the traffic.
So that's horizontal pod auto scaling with the
metrics adapter
using a flux query annotated on the HPA.
I hope you find that useful, and there'll
be a blog published shortly and a link
at the end of this video. Thank you
very much.